I really believe that those guys doing
this is huge for MMA I really do I mean
they didn't say they were going to have
a a boxing match they said they were
going to have an MMA match and
Zuckerberg is practicing grappling what
was the last person you know big
celebrity that focused on grappling and
not you know boxing it it's
unprecedented that we've seen somebody
at the people at this level pushed MMA
not boxing MMA not karate MMA not
sitting at a Pistons game we need them
pushing this they are some of the
highest political figures in the world
and politics is leading the world right
now and it's not necessarily always
going in a as anybody would agree a
perfect Direction letting the world hash
that out on a public forum with two
people who don't fight can't fight is
almost like therapeutic how many people
want to be in there doing that and can
and because these guys are so rich and
so have so much influence they get the
opportunity